[Musique]
trop de facilité souvent trop d'argent
et surtout si les parents ne sommes nous
pas assez il est laid s'il laisse les
jeunes pour avoir leur paient leur
tranquillité les laisser faire ce qu'ils
veulent et je trouve qu'il est beaucoup
plus facile de toujours cédé que de dire
non à les jeunes surtout entre 14 et 18
ans qui ne sont pas assez surveillé par
les parents ils ont un peu trop de
liberté à mon avis et il fréquente
beaucoup les cinémas certainement aux
fréquentations des enfants et ensuite à
une question que l'on peut peut-être que
appelé sinon c'est à dire ceux qui ont
trop d'argent
ceux qui n'ont pas assez ceux qui ont
trop les blousons dorés les autres on
les connaît en général je crois que le
milieu familial joue beaucoup des jeunes
gens voient qu'il y a beaucoup de gains
très facile et puis alors ils se disent
pour paco pas pourquoi pas moi et des
jeunes qui peuvent parce qu'un être que
d'autres jany peut se permettre alors
ils cherchent pas solution tout -
devenir plus qu'ils sont devenir artiste
les lignes asif de lumière tout ils
auront leur idole hallyday y ait
d'autres puits alors et dans chaque
personne champ et il ya un petit
hallyday qui dort et qui sommeille et
finike qui alors ils croient pourquoi
pas moi parce que
c'est tellement facile à gagner de
l'argent à leurs yeux qu'ils sont
obligés de travailler à gagner quelques
sous par tous la différence est trop
grand et bien la lecture des romans de
série noire la jeunesse en soie olive et
à elle-même étant donné que les parents
sortent travailler et puis des films
devant auxerre et aussi les revues et
puis il ya encore quelque chose
la jeunesse en ce moment elle ne voit
pas l'avenir
c'est extrêmement difficile à dire pour
un homme de mon âge parce que je crois
que nous ne sommes plus dans le coup ça
il faudrait d'abord éduquer les parents
des parents c'est la faute du temps
modernes les sentiments familiaux ont
dit non énormément diminuer les enfants
ne non plus le respect de leurs parents
comme il l'avait dans le temps mais
s'étendent sur un tel sujet tour est
peut-être un petit peu au ridicule je
n'aurais pas faire sourire
[Musique]